[Musique]
bonsoir nouvelle semaine d'information
locale sur tv 78 très heureux de vous
retrouver pour ce journal voici les
titres de ce lundi 6 juillet c'était il
ya un an l'usiné de traitement des eaux
usées du sia pas cher et est en partie
détruite par un incendie
l incident avait engendré une pollution
de la senne ce matin un point d'étape a
été dressée sur l'évolution de la
situation
suite logique du second tour des
élections municipales les conseils
d'installation se déroulait ce week-end
dans les communes pour désigner maires
et adjoints et plusieurs nouveaux édiles
ont été élus lors de ces séances le
point à suivre enfin les usagers étaient
impatients de pouvoir plonger à nouveau
dans ses bassins la piscine salvador
allende a rouvert ce matin aux clayes
sous bois
pour ce faire des mesures sanitaires
strictes ont été mises en place
c'était le 3 juillet 2019 l' usine de
traitement des eaux usées du siaap à
achères était victime d'un incendie 6000
mètres carrés de bâtiments partis en
fumée un an plus tard une réunion était
organisée ce matin en sous-préfecture de
saint-germain-en-laye avec tous les
acteurs du dossier
objectif faire le point sur la situation
les détails de nicolas d'ambri voici les
premières images du futur bâtiment de
l'usiné de traitement des eaux usées du
siaap à achères une reconstruction suite
à l' incendie du 3 juillet 2019 une
nouvelle organisation autour de deux
bâtiments avec un site réservé au
stockage de chlorure ferrique à
l'intérieur du bâtiment de la classe
population ce qui a surtout brûlé c'est
le stockage de chlorure ferrique donc ce
stockage là on va le reconstruire à côté
et du coup avec des mesures en termes de
sécurité incendie qui sont beaucoup plus
draconiennes que celles dont on
disposait dans l'ancien bâtiment
depuis un an le bâtiment touché par
l'incendié a été nettoyé les travaux de
reconstruction devraient être lancés en
2021 pour une livraison en 2022
en attendant le siaap travaille sur une
nouvelle organisation
objectif renforcer la sécurité
aujourd'hui on est encore dans une
culture où c'est la production donc le
traitement des eaux qui est la priorité
est la sécurité n'est pas encore une
priorité suffisamment importante pour
l'ensemble de nos agents et notamment
pour nos encadrants donc c'est ce
travail là qu'on va mener dans les deux
trois ans qui viennent
les résultats d'un audit et d'une
expertise sur l'origine de cet incendie
ont été présentés lors d'une réunion
d'information auprès des parties
prenantes à la sous-préfecture de
saint-germain-en-laye
la cause la plus probable du départ de
feu serait un défaut d'isolement de
câbles électriques
l'incendié étant d'origine électrique il
est susceptible de se reproduire et
qu'il faut donc d'une part diminuer ce
risque et surtout en limiter les
conséquences pour rassurer les élus
locaux et la population les services de
l'état poursuivent la communication sur
ce dossier
des exercices de sécurité devrait être
organisé en novembre au niveau des
opérations de commandement puis avec les
maires et la population en avril 2021
une semaine après le second tour des
élections municipales les conseils
d'installation se déroulait ce week-end
dans les communes à trappes il s'est
tenu vendredi après une campagne sous
tension ali rabais arrivé en tête du
scrutin avec sa liste la gauche unie
pour que tu rappes respire a été élu
nouveau maire de la ville dans
l'opposition de groupe mené par othman
neuf trous et le maire sortant guy
malandain les précisions de mathilde
domini et d'aurélien ans
pour ce conseil d'installation c'est guy
malandain doyen de l'assemblée qui a
présidé la séance pour élire son
successeur après un vote à bulletin
secret sans surprise c'est à les rabais
qui devient officiellement maire de
trappes 28 votes contre 11 pour son
adversaire
othman menace que mon équipe est déjà au
travail
je dors peu mais je suis fière et ravie
et honorée d'avoir été choisie par les
trappistes pour être leur mère
nous avons pris immédiatement des
décisions importantes pour préparer
notamment la rentrée scolaire le passage
à la semaine de quatre jours
je suis fier d'annoncer aux trappistes
pouvoir une première promesse tenue
on conseille quelque peu agitée à
l'image d'une campagne difficile
al'annonce de l'élection de son
successeur guy malandain quitte la salle
après avoir occupé le siège de premier
magistrat de la ville pendant 19 ans je
suis lui tende que je pourrais servir
les habitants même dans une fonction
d'opposition je le ferai je dois pas
d'opposition systématique si si c'est si
c'est bien c'est bien croire je suis pas
je suis pas un fou politicards qui dit
non par principe à tout ce que les
autres décident on met à écrire la
discorde entre les deux listes la gauche
unie pour que tu rappes respire d'avira
b et engagement trappe citoyen d'hotman
natrue le nouveau maire souhaite un
terrain bon temps afin de travailler
sereinement avec l'opposition
j'aurai un dialogue respectueux avec
l'opposition
je les invitais d'ailleurs à quitter les
postures d'opposition de principe et à
rentrer dans une dynamique de
propositions j'attends des actes pas de
déclarations d'intention les méthodes de
campagne qui qui ont eu lieu que chacun
a pu voir - ont profondément inquiété et
me laisse penser que les déclarations
d'aujourd'hui ne seront pas forcément
suivies de faits mais si c'est le cas
nous serons comme nous avons toujours
été une opposition constructive qui
cherchent des solutions
un recours a tout de même été déposée
par la liste d'hotman menaceront
engagement trappe citoyen pour invalider
l'élection
à la verrière le nouveau conseil
municipal a été installé samedi matin
sans surprise après le résultat du
second tour nicolas dainville a été
nommé maire de la ville qui bascule donc
à droite après 43 ans de gestion
communiste est la maire sortante nelly
duthu siégera quant à elle dans
l'opposition nickel et demi d'euros
bastion communiste depuis 1977 la ville
de la verrière passe officiellement à
droite
moins d'une semaine après sa victoire
lors du second tour des municipales
nicolas dainville a été intronisé ce
samedi 4 juillet lors du conseil
municipal d'installation organisé dans
la salle le scarabée beaucoup d'émotion
beaucoup des maisons d'émotion de
revêtir cette écharpe tricolore d'être
au service d'une ville d'avoir la
confiance les habitants faut maintenant
rassembler le temps de la campagne est
terminée c'est le temps du travail pour
agir très concrètement pour m
en place nos engagements sur l'éducation
la sécurité sur les grands dossiers de
la ville la maire sortante communiste
nelly youtube battu siègera dans
l'opposition avec cinq autres membres de
sa liste
on avait plein de projets notre liste
était
enthousiaste bon
c'est comme ça maintenant on va
travailler dans nos positions et on va
faire attention à tout ce qui se fait
être attentif à ce que les intérêts des
bernois soient toujours
en premier jean yves mulet arrivé
troisième de ces élections municipales
occupera lui un siège dans l'opposition
je pourrais avec madame du tout comme je
pourrais être avec monsieur dainville
tout dépendra des projets qui seront
présentés c'est tout là
c'est tout l'enjeu huit adjoints de la
liste de nicolas david ont également été
désignés lors de ce conseil
selon leurs compétences selon leur
origine selon leur quartier donc avec
des gens qui sont d'origine air plutôt
du bois de l'étang d'orly par go du
village j'ai essayé aussi d'avoir dans
les âges
une diversité avec des gens peu plus
expérimenté d'autres un peu plus jeunes
donc on a une belle équipe
le prochain conseil municipal sera
organisé le 16 juillet prochain l'ordre
du jour le budget lui aussi est un
nouveau maire des yvelines s'est même à
25 ans le benjamin dans le département
et aussi dans la région ile-de-france
bonsoir geoffroy abax de keating bonsoir
vous êtes le nouveau maire du coup dû à
perray-en-yvelines vous avez été désigné
samedi à la suite du conseil municipal
d'installation pendant ce conseil
municipal alors le 28 juin dernier votre
liste s'est classé en première position
dans la commune face à la liste de la
maire sortante paulette deschamps qui
était depuis 1999 à la tête de la
commune déjà devenir le maire le plus
jeunes d'ile-de-france devenir le le
maire du perray-en-yvelines est ce que
c'est un motif déjà de fierté pour vous
fierté je ne sais pas à fierté en tout
cas d'avoir eu la confiance des
électeurs parce que c'est pas gagné
quand on a mon âge je remercie
énormément les électeurs qui ont fait le
choix du renouveau après comme vous
l'avez dit 20 ans de mandat de gestion
socialiste par madame deschamps et du
coup devenir à 25 ans le maire du
perray-en-yvelines être le plus jeunes
maires d'ile-de-france est ce que c'est
quelque chose qui vous fait peur qu est
ce que vous pouvez répondre à ceux qui
avancerait l'argument
du manque d'expérience peut être quand
il ils commandent votre élection
oui alors après j'arrive avec humilité
évidemment quand on a cet âge là ils
sont toujours arrivés avec l'humilité on
est là pour dans un premier temps
prendre ses marques à prendre rapidement
beaucoup de dossiers à travailler alors
après moi j'avais j'ai mon expérience
actuelle de directeur de cabinet d'un
établissement public qui me permet quand
même d'appréhender la gestion d'une
collectivité locale donc sur ce point là
il n'y a pas trop de difficultés je suis
aussi également très bien entouré j'ai
une équipe qui est complémentaire de
tous les âges des anciens conseillers
municipaux
voilà et puis évidemment une bonne
administration qui m'accompagnent dans
la gestion au quotidien
alors si on revient sur l'élection
municipale opérait en yvelines vous
accusiez après le premier tour en retard
de huit points sur la liste de la maire
sortante maire sortante que vous avez
donc battu au second tour dans
l'entre-deux tours je précise que vous
avez fusionner votre liste avec celle
d'un autre candidat qui est arrivé en
quatrième position
qu'est-ce qui a fait la différence selon
vous qu'est ce qui a permis de vous
donner cette cette victoire dans la
commune je crois que c'est lent vie
voilà quand vous montrez l'envi la
motivation on a fait énormément de
terrain même après le confinement c'est
vrai que c'est une période qui a été un
peu compliqué à vivre non seulement pour
les habitants mais pour nous aussi qui
ne pouvions faire campagne et faire
passer les messages il y avait un
contexte sanitaire qui était quand même
bien plus important mais dès la sortie
du confinement nous avons renoué le
dialogue très rapidement avec les
perrotin nous avons été sur le terrain
c'est beaucoup de présence physique
alors malheureusement ne pouvions pas de
faire de porte à porte ou de réunions
publiques
mais en tout cas nous avons fait
beaucoup de terrain on a prit même une
permanence électorale pour une douzaine
de jours c'est ce sont toutes ces
actions là qui ont permis vraiment de
deux marques et notre présence physique
est toujours de convaincre jusqu'au bout
et quand on est dans des niveaux de
différence de voix comme celui ci c'est
vraiment la motivation qui qui a joué je
le disais vous êtes officiellement mer
depuis samedi puisque le conseil
d'installation avait lieu
samedi dans la commune à quoi vous
ressemblez vos premières semaines de mer
quelles vont être les premières
décisions que vous allez prendre
opéré en yvelines alors il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de travail
la dent à court terme évidemment vous
devez reprendre la gestion quotidienne
le 14 juillet donc il y aura pas de feu
d'artifice malheureusement par rapport
au contexte sanitaire mais dès
maintenant on a voulu montrer le
dynamisme que l'on voulait instaurer
dans la commune ce pour ça qu'on va
faire le premier marché nocturne de
l'artisanat et de la gastronomie locale
opérant olivier qui va attirer plus
d'une vingtaine d'exposants duperré et
des alentours avec des animations pour
les enfants de la restauration en
terrasse voilà donc déjà dead à notre
début de mandat nous voulons montrer ce
dynamisme et esprit village que nous
voulions faire vivre à nouveau
et puis il ya d'autres sujets plus de
fond comme la préservation de notre
cadre de vie de l'environnement il y à
un méga projet d'urbanisation sur le
site de la perche marc 450 logements qui
avait été entamé par la municipalité
sortant que nous avons évidemment
l'ambition d' arrêter ce projet
donc c'est beaucoup de travail j'ai déjà
pris le contact avec nexity l'aménageur
pour arriver à une issue sur ce projet
pour vraiment pouvoir l'arrêter
et puis enfin on prépare évidemment la
rentrée scolaire on a pour ambition de
mettre en place un soutien scolaire en
ligne gratuit pour tous les jeunes
perrotin donc voilà les actions sur
lesquelles on est en train de travailler
actuellement
vous parlez de l'environnement on sait
c'est une affaire qui avait fait parlé
au niveau local au niveau national aussi
l'arrêté anti pesticides pris par
paulette deschamps qui avait été ensuite
débouté par la justice l'environnement
ça c'est une question centrale
opérant divine ça va faire partie de vos
priorités vous le disiez il ya un
instant tout à fait mais nous ce que
parce que ce que nous voulons dénoncer
ce que nous avons dénoncé pendant cette
campagne c'était le double discours de
madame deschamps qui s'opposait au
glyphosate mais a été le maire qui a le
plus urbanisées sur cette dernière
décennie dans toute l'agglomération
rambouillet territoire ce sont près de
31 hectares d'espacés naturels qui ont
été supprimés
le projet de la perche omar qui devait
s'implanter sur 7 hectares place des
espaces naturels
nous notre première action écologique
c'est d'abord de préserver les espaces
naturels de la commune
c'est ce qui fait aussi la richesse du
cadre de vie du terrain ni blesser ce
pourquoi les gens viennent s'installer
aujourd'hui au père est donc d'abord
préservation de notre environnement et
ensuite évidemment il ya d'autres
actions comme l'aide aux mobilités
douces les l'ouverture de nouveaux
espaces naturels voilà voilà les actions
qui vont venir dans le mandat qui vient
merci geoffroy back the keating d'avoir
est avec nous merci beaucoup mère du
père en heavy le nouveau maire du perray
en yvelines et je précise encore pour
ceux qui nous rejoignent que vous êtes à
ce jour le plus jeunes maires d'île de
france
[Musique]
lui aussi est un jeune mère à 28 ans il
est le nouvel édile de villepreux jean
baptiste à monique vainqueur avec 55 71
% des suffrages lors du second tour a
été intronisé par le conseil municipal
de la ville samedi matin
il succède à stéphane mirambeau qui a
été maire de la ville pendant 12 ans
reportage de michael et demi d'euros
jean baptiste à monique est
officiellement le nouveau maire de
villepreux l'homme politique de 28 ans
vainqueur du second tour des municipales
dans la ville a été intronisé par le
conseil municipal d'installation ce
samedi 4 juillet on a beaucoup de
retours positifs on les sent on sent les
on sent les villes projets en attente
évidemment de voir quels seront nos
premières décisions mais on sent je vais
dire un soulagement
pour pour les villes provient de
d'ouvrir une nouvelle un nouveau
chapitre d'ouvrir une nouvelle page
arrivé troisième lors du second tour le
maire sortant stéphane mirambeau ne
siègera pas dans l'opposition au
contraire de valérie bain qui a réalisé
25 68 % le 28 juin dernier
l'esprit ouvert voilà il ya il ya
forcément des choses qui vont se
produire et on espère et contribué le
plus largement possible avec nos moyens
on est toujours dans la construction
contre l'immobilier massif mais toujours
dans la construction de projets au
service des villes provient la nouvelle
équipe municipale et ses 33 membres
espère maintenant se mettre au travail
rapidement les grands dossiers en tout
cas les priorités du moment ça va être
de pouvoir gérer dans les meilleures
conditions la rentrée scolaire si on
l'avait dit on a un retard de l'école du
groupe scolaire des ou dumoulin ce qui
va entraîner certaines problématiques
notamment en termes d'effectifs dans les
classes donc on va prendre dès le budget
qui sera voté la semaine prochaine des
décisions importantes
il y aura évidemment un soutien apporté
à la vie associative et aux acteurs
locaux
je pense notamment à la sortie du
confinement et au contexte sanitaire
avec les impacts économiques et sociaux
qui vont arriver devant nous le prochain
conseil municipal sera programmée le
vendredi 10 juillet à 18 heures avec à
l'ordre du jour le budget lui était
maire sortant et il repart pour un
nouveau mandat à guyancourt françois
morton a été réélu lors du conseil
municipal d'installation samedi à la
ferme de bel ébat il débute à un premier
mandat complet lui qui avait succédé à
marie christine le tarnec démissionnaire
l'an passé dans son discours
d'intronisation françois marteau a
détaillé les priorités pour les six
prochaines années
solidarité éducation transition
écologique démocratie locale
à noter qu'olivier paris jacky avait
fusionné sa liste avec celle du maire
entre les deux tours devient adjoint en
charge de la démocratie permanente
rodolphe baril et grégory pape tous deux
candidats au second tour sont à la tête
de deux groupes d'opposition avec
respectivement 5 et 3 sièges
[Musique]
pour refermer ce journal vous avez
peut-être aperçu cet attroupement ce
matin à la piscine salvador allende des
clayes sous bois
et pour cause elle rouvrait ses portes
après plus de trois mois de fermeture et
munis de masques les usagers devaient au
préalable réservé pour venir faire
quelques longueurs dans les bassins sur
place manon varaldo toute l'équipe
s'active pour l'ouverture de la piscine
elle dispose de trois bassins le plus
grand découvrable de 25 mètres carrés un
autre bassin et une pataugeoire cette
dernière et non utilisables pour limiter
les risques de propagation du virus
les extérieurs sont fermés également un
protocole sanitaire pour les usagers est
de rigueur
les clients n'utiliseront pas
les casiers faudra voir un sac et on
mettra les affaires dans le sac les gens
rentreront dans une cabine un parent
cabine habituellement la piscine et
d'une capacité d'accueil de 500
personnes avec la crise sanitaire la
capacité des vestiaires permet de
recevoir sur réservation 30 personnes
maximum et jetteront leurs masques et il
faudra se doucher savonnage obligatoire
ça sera contrôlée ils passeront ensuite
ils viendront nager au bassin un créneau
d'une heure trente
ouh là si vous avez des affaires du
style blanche masques et tout ça il
faudra les désinfecter dans un container
on viendra nager ensuite au bassin il y
aura trois zones qui seront dédiés une
au jeu une aux nageurs confirmés une
plus nash détente pour accéder à la
piscine il faut réserver minimum 48
heures à l'avancé
entre chaque créneau il y à débattement
d'une heure elle nécessaire pour la
désinfection des vestiaires le bassin et
les sanitaires ce qui provoque une files
d'attentes
je viens pour le premier jour parce que
la piscine me manquait depuis le début
du confinement
donc j'ai procédé à la réservation sur
internet
il est effectivement 12h20 une créneau
est censé durer à midi c'est un petit
temps de mise en route je pense les
créneaux de réservation sont disponibles
sur la plateforme sky point fr c'est la
fin de ce journal merci de votre
fidélité très belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]